[Applaus]
[Musik]
die volksrepublik china ist die
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
verfügt über die größte produzierende
industrie der welt und auch in ihrer
bedeutung als internationaler akteur
steht sie sich immer weiter an die
spitze und trotzdem eine liegen
zuschauer handelt es sich immer noch um
ein sehr unnahbare und weitgehend
unbekanntes land dessen image weiterhin
von großen klischees und mythen umgeben
ist die entweder nie oder bestenfalls
nicht mehr der realität entsprechen
zumindest nicht ganz wir werden es heute
drei der größten mythen ansehen die sich
immer wieder um die chinesische
wirtschaft ranken drei große lügen oder
halbwahrheiten und du sicher schon oft
gehört hast und die du wahrscheinlich
auch geglaubt hast bevor wir jedoch mit
dem zerstören dieser mythen beginnen
erlaubt mir ein wenig werbung für
unseren sponsor stark zu machen der das
heutige video möglich gemacht hat libyen
ist ein wirklich sicheres vpn dass ich
auch selbst zu meiner vollsten
zufriedenheit nutzt okay aber wozu
braucht man eigentlich ein virtual
private network vpn nun da wären gleich
mehrere vorteile zum einen erschwerten
kombinationen anderen vorklärungen eure
aktionen messen nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören es bietet viele sicherheits
features mit denen ihr eure anonymität
indes erhöht zum beispiel klien wird
dass alle cookies popups und so weiter
bloggt und die damit verbundenen
gefahren beseitigt ein weiterer vorteil
des ortes dass ihr so tun können als
derer die an einem anderen ort so könnte
zum beispiel auf webseiten und internet
dienste zugreifen in dem land seit ich
das super deren ob daheim oder im urlaub
damit schlag die zensur und timo glock
je ein schnippchen netflix und andere
streaming diensten ihre inhalte nur in
den usa anbieten von europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches internet fernsehen im
ausland gucken mit surf kein problem
aber das ist noch lange nicht alles denn
mit nur einem surf lag und ihr könnt ihr
wirklich alle eure endgeräte im vgn
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
eurem smart tvs so und wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angibt bekommt ihr
vorschlag auch noch ein rabatt von 83%
obendrein die ersten drei monate gratis
dazu den link zu diesem angebot findet
ihr eine beschreibung unter diesem video
also nichts wie los besorgt als surfer
und greift damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
paypal spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die beschreibung gebracht
habe wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hält
uns euch in zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere videos zu liefern so nun zurück
ins reich der mitte lasst uns die mythen
einen nach dem anderen sagt trümmern
[Musik]
mythos 1 nichts als eine große export
von china
hat sich in den letzten jahrzehnten
stark verändert seit deng xiaoping 1978
in öffnungsprozess einleitete hat china
den größten wirtschaftlichen aufschwung
der geschichte erlebt in den letzten 40
jahren verzeichnete dieses land ein
durchschnittliches jährliches
wirtschaftswachstum von fast zehn
prozent und das inflationsbereinigte pro
kopf bip stieg um mehr als das 24-fache
wodurch mehr als 800 millionen menschen
mehr als die gesamte bevölkerung
lateinamerikas kanadas und der
niederlande zusammengenommen die armut
hinter sich lassen konnten und ja es
stimmt bei dieser ganzen entwicklung hat
der exportsektor eine schlüsselrolle
gespielt aber mit 1,4 milliarden
verbraucher und einer mittelschicht die
mehr als 600 millionen chinesen umfasst
geht die wirtschaft dieses landes weit
darüber hinaus
der vielleicht größte mythos über chinas
rasante modernisierung und
wirtschaftliche entwicklung ist das ein
wachstum nur durch den export
angetrieben wurde chinas
wirtschaftlicher wandel ist jedoch
vielmehr auf die erfolgreiche einführung
einer marktbasierten binnenwirtschaft
und enorm mobilisierung von ersparnissen
zur investitionen zurückzuführen
tatsächlich liegt der anteil der exporte
am bip in china bei nur knapp 19 prozent
das ist ein ähnlicher anteil die in
brasilien oder indien aber viel
niedriger als in ländern wie kanada
frankreich italien oder großbritannien
und es kommt noch nicht mal ansatzweise
an deutschland mit seiner exportquote
von über 47,5 prozent heran ganz genau
der anteil export an bip deutschlands
übersteigt in china um mehr als 28
prozent punkte also ja den absoluten
zahlen ist china der größte exporteur
der welt fast zehn prozent aller
weltweit exportierten waren kommen aus
diesem land aber das liegt auch daran
dass wir über die wirtschaft eines
riesigen landes sprechen china
exportiert fahrstil aber das eigentliche
wirtschaftliche herz des landes liegt
auf dem heimischen markt genauer gesagt
auf den investitions markt im markt der
produktionsfaktoren der sogenannten
protokoll bildung um euch eine
vorstellung davon zu geben china erspart
und investiert mehr als 40 prozent sein
die ib in inland etwa doppelt so viel
wie in den westlichen ländern üblich
[Musik]
maschinen kräne immobilien dämme straßen
investitionen in wohngebäude
transportmittel infrastruktur und
produktionszentren waren für den größten
teil des wirtschaftswachstums des landes
verantwortlich wer jetzt allerdings
meint dies seien nur gute nachrichten
verschiedener art all dies ist in großen
teilen mit zentralen wirtschaft
verbunden und basiert nicht auf vielen
kleinteiligen entscheidungen vieler
marktteilnehmer sondern eher auf
machtkonzentration und auf der
allokation von ressourcen nach dem
gießkannenprinzip durch wenige große
akteure dadurch kann das
optimierungspotenzial von
marktmechanismen nicht in großem maße
aktiviert werden und es kommt zu
massiver verschwendung welche die
produktivität drückt tatsächlich haben
die wichtigsten wirtschaftlichen
schwierigkeiten mit in china derzeit
konfrontiert ist genau mit dieser
eigenschaft zu tun wir sprechen vor
allem über probleme wie über
investitionen fehlallokation von kapital
die verschwendung von rohstoffen und
auch menschliche arbeiten von einem
dadurch geringeren produktivitätsniveau
masse statt klasse eben aber dieses
thema haben wir bereits einen früheren
video genau auseinander genommen und aus
diesem grund versucht die chinesische
regierung seit jahren den lokalen konsum
anzukurbeln damit sich die
wirtschaftsstruktur des landes zu einem
modell entwickelt das den der reicheren
länder ähnlicher ist mit anderen worten
wenn wir über die aussichten und
entwicklung der chinesischen wirtschaft
sprechen liegt der schlüssel nicht so
sehr in den exporten sondern in den
kapitalmärkten und den produktiv
faktoren
mythos 2 alle ausländischen investoren
fliehen aber china
wo kenne dass die chinesische wirtschaft
momentan nicht ihre beste zeit erlebt
ist ein offenes geheimnis der
handelskrieg die pandemie springs
kampagne des gemeinsamen wohlstand die
in die höhe schießen und energiepreise
die immobilienkrise und die zero korrekt
politik setzen der chinesischen
wirtschaft arg zu trotzdem kann man
nicht sagen dass ausländische investoren
massenhaft abwandern oder dass es die
regierung selbst ist die ausländischen
investitionen einschränkt
denn es ist die eine sache ein
investitionsprojekt einzufrieren oder in
ein anderes land zu verlagern um eine
größere diversifizierung der
produktionsketten anzustreben aber eine
ganz andere
in den letzten jahrzehnten
eingeschlagenen weg komplett zurück zu
rollen und vergesst eines nicht es gibt
heute schlicht und einfach keine
gleichwertige alternative zur china
schaut euch genau an was im jahr 2020
passiert ist
25 januar 2021 china ist auf den weg zur
weltspitze zum ersten mal überholt ist
die usa als wichtigstes ziel für
ausländische direktinvestitionen und
2021 verzeichnisse es reicht damit
erneut den größten zufluss ausländischer
direktinvestitionen in seiner gesamten
geschichte jeder fünfte dollar an
direktinvestitionen weltweit ging an
diesen asiatischen riesen
[Musik]
darüber hinaus legen die chinesische
regierung ausländische investitionen
nicht nur nicht ab sondern ist sich auch
darüber im klaren dass sie sie braucht
ein beweis dafür ist dass peking in den
letzten jahren immer näher
wirtschaftsbereiche für außenseiter
eröffnet hat und das internationale
unternehmen sogar erleichtert hat mit
100 prozentigen tochtergesellschaften im
land tätig zu sein ganz genau im
gegensatz zu ihrer früheren politik hat
die chinesische regierung 2021 sogar us
investmentbanken die genehmigung erteilt
in china mit hundertprozentigen
tochtergesellschaften tätig zu sein es
stimmt zwar dass die zero comic politik
diese offenheit eine schwere schlag
versetzt hat nicht zuletzt weil sie die
grenzen des landes der human capital
schließt und wichtige ausländische
kompetenzträger vertreibt aber alle
hoffen dass dies nur ein vorübergehender
zustand sein wird auch wenn er bereits
zu einer schweren traumatisierung und
reputation schädigung geführt hat die
nur über jahre wieder geheilt werden
kann
mythos nummer drei chinas wirtschaft ist
für die usa eine echte herausforderung
der dritte und letzte große motors hat
mit chinas wirtschaftskraft und seiner
fähigkeit zu tun mit den vereinigten
staaten auf augenhöhe zu konkurrieren
die weltbank rest dass die chinesische
wirtschaft bereinigt um das preisgefälle
bereits größer ist als die der usa
die interpretation dieser statistik kann
jedoch zu großen missverständnissen
führen china hat sich zwar sprunghaft
entwickelt aber sein abstand zu den
reichsten ländern ist immer noch
galaktisch groß tatsächlich handelt es
sich um ein land das immer noch nicht
als wohlhabend bezeichnet werden kann
nach angaben der weltbank liegt das pro
kopf bip des landes bei etwas mehr als
10.000 dollar was einem viertel des pro
kopf bip der europäischen union um knapp
20 prozent des bip der vereinigten
staaten entspricht und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass genau dieser faktor die
kaufkraft und die internationalen
investitionen bestimmt
die chinesische wirtschaft ist sehr groß
denn wir sprechen über das
bevölkerungsreichste land der erde in
einer von fünf menschen die auf diesen
planeten herum keuchen lebt in china
aber von den 1,4 milliarden menschen die
in der volksrepublik china leben können
nur 600 millionen zur mittelschicht
gezielt werden wohlgemerkt mittelschicht
bezogen auf chinesische verhältnisse
nicht europäische oder amerikanische
außerdem ist das dp ein recht grobe
indikator der viele probleme mit sich
bringt es misst nicht die produktivität
es müsse nicht den verbrauch der
produktionsfaktoren oder die
überschussproduktion die letztendlich
den wohlstand und die wohlstands bild
druck ausmachen es wird durch viele
einflüsse wie den staatsanteil und ja
auch manipulations verzerrt darüber wie
china seine wirtschaftsdaten seit jahren
fälscht haben wir sogar ein eigenes
video gedreht das ich euch verlinken
werne
[Musik]
all dies erklärt also warum sich nach
angaben der credit suisse die vermögens-
kluft zwischen us amerikanischen und
chinesischen familien seit 2011 nicht
verkleinert sondern weiter vergrößert
hat uns warum sage und schreibe zwölf
billionen dollar wir müssen auch
berücksichtigen dass wir hier über ein
sehr großes lang mit vielen
unterschieden nicht nur in bezug auf die
bevölkerung sondern auch in bezug auf
die regionen sprechen eben gegensatz zu
den großen küstenstädten sind die
gebiete im landesinneren noch immer
relativ arm und die regierung hat große
probleme die verbleibende
landbevölkerung versprechen sie von mehr
als einer halben milliarde menschen
ausreichend zu qualifizieren und in
höherwertige wertschöpfungsprozesse zu
integrieren und bevor sie über alter und
zu einer großen belastung wird ganz
genau so wie europas zum beispiel darin
versagt große gruppen von einwanderern
in bestehende wertschöpfungsprozesse auf
dem produktionsniveau der einheimische
bevölkerung einzugliedern bevor diese
die sozialsysteme aussaugen wird china
in einer ganz ähnlichen herausforderung
scheitern und dass diese die arme und
niedrigqualifizierte landbevölkerung
betrifft und diese um ein vielfaches
größer ist kurz gesagt china als ganzes
kann nicht als wohlhabendes land
betrachtet werden und es scheint auch
nicht so als ob es diesen status
erreichen könnte bevor es massenhaft
über altert mit der wirtschaftskraft der
vereinigten staaten kann es so auf jeden
fall nicht mithalten und wird dazu auch
in zukunft nicht in der lage sein das
also sind die drei grossen mythen über
die chinesische wirtschaft die in vielen
medien und in vielen gesprächen immer
wieder auftauchen wie alle sollten sie
von nun an im auge behalten denn die
darin maßgeblichen faktoren werden auch
die entwicklung der globalen wirtschaft
und biopolitik grundlegend bestimmen und
letztendlich auch unser aller leben
daher werden wir sie noch in vielen
zukünftigen videos thematisieren und
analysieren damit ihr im bilde bleibt
vergesst nicht dass ab und vor allem
nicht dass benachrichtigungs glöckchen
und keines unserer spannenden videos
mehr zu verpassen und jetzt seid ihr
erst mal mit euren analysen an der reihe
glaubt ihr dass sich jeder von seinen
jüngsten wirtschaftlichen problemen
erholen wird habt ihr jemals darüber
nachgedacht in china tätig zu werden
dort zu investieren oder waren auf den
chinesischen markt zu verkaufen
vielleicht arbeitet ja in einem
unternehmen welches dieses dreist tut
oder vorrat hat uns doch über eure
eindrücke
paarungen und erwartungen die immer sind
auf eure diskussionsbeiträge zu diesem
thema im kommentarbereich schon mächtig
gespannt und zu guter letzt möchten wir
uns bei unseren freunden von der pace
cool für die zusammenarbeit bei der
erstellung dieses videos bedanken ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat und jetzt vielleicht auch etwas
dabei gelernt habt fast usecon anleihen
test mit und freunde und natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
spende von uns hält dieses projekt und
weiterzuführen den peter link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung oder dem
video macht es gut und bis bald